okay all right do you guys want up do ya
baby better all right yeah
give it to me okay you're gonna have to
be a little more specific than that
stand against honey
okay can't give me an example okay like
such as I mean can give me an actual
example in what case would it do that
wouldn't a human also be vulnerable of
that as well
she says who what's happy about hacking
is about convincing someone for example
getting a part password right getting
some master password
it's about convincing the system that
you ask someone who you are not right
but if you must do that all the time
like you know that kind of interaction
and being able full someone is not new
to the 20 age so what's your real issue
okay I'm actually gonna I'm gonna do a
thing our different mats which is if you
guys haven't got this on any jam if you
see the lit as I a stencil ignore
subsequent error because it means you do
time right and then you screw it up
later on and you know okay I'll just
pretend I never saw that okay so I'm
gonna go in what you said earlier what
sunny wasagamack okay which is that it
lacks ethics okay so if your decision
requires some kind of a moral choice or
value to us or an ethical choice which
most people generally would not trust
the computer to make an ethical decision
for us right maybe an accurate decision
but not necessarily an ethical or right
decision or a just decision okay yeah
not quite not quite not really emotions
and ethics are I think they're quite
distinct they're not they overlap but
they're quite a thing okay do you guys
gonna raise it any more
we're on 1 2 3 4 5 here up 1 2 3 4 5 6
here ok so yeah all right so you
uniqueness okay I'm running out of space
on this boy would you all like to
qualify
but I'm gonna only raise this next time
I'm gonna give you a matter of 15
seconds per answer sir no Omega nari
okay give me your answer and if you
can't do it that time then it's over
okay